>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: Good morning.
>> Class: Good morning.
>> Karen Jaffe: If you go
to Whittier Education
Campus, raise your hand.
All right.
Welcome first graders to
the Young Reader's Center.
My name is Karen Jaffe.
I'm head of the Young
Reader's Center,
and you are in the
Library of Congress.
Has anyone been to the
Library of Congress before?
Terrific. Thank you.
Well, that means that we hope
many more of you will come back,
and come back to visit us in
the Young Reader's Center.
Today, we have a special program
with our friends, "Everyone
Wins D.C."
who is bringing you together,
with us, for a special story time.
And, today the story time is with
two Capitol Hill police officers.
They are Renee White and Tech
Tiffany White, and guess what?
Hunter, the K-9.
Okay? And, he's part
of this program.
So, I'm going to ask
Officer White to read a story
about police officers,
and then Tech White
and Officer White will be talking to
you a little bit about what they do,
what their job is at
the Capitol Hill Police,
and then you can ask
them some questions.
Okay? So, we are going to ask
that you not ask any questions
until they finish with the program,
and then you can ask the questions,
and then you'll have a chance
to meet Hunter yourself.
Okay? So, here we go.
>> Renee White: Good morning.
>> Class: Good morning.
>> Renee White: I will be reading
"Let's Meet a Police Officer."
>> Renee White: Officer White,
I kind of changed the name,
because this officer's name
in here is Officer Gabby,
but I'm going to say Officer
White which is myself.
Today, our class is
having a visitor.
We're going to find out
what a police officer does.
We invited Officer White.
She works at our school.
"I keep our neighborhood safe"
says Officer White, "And,
our school" says Madeline.
Officer White is a
school resource officer.
That's her assignment,
making students safe.
It's her job.
She stopped cars at the cross walk.
She warns us about strangers.
"Did you get your assignment
from police school?"
says Phoebe, the little
girl asked her.
"From my police department"
says Officer White.
"First, I was a patrol officer.
It was part of my training.
I worked hard.
Then, I got a new assignment.
We're happy."
See, she's very happy.
[ Silence ]
Officer Tech White and
K-9 Officer, Hunter.
Most officers wear police
uniforms, special clothes
and tools are part of this uniform.
"1051 at 1422 Pine Street."
Officer White uniform is talking.
"What's that noise?"
says Beckie.
"My police radio" she says.
Officer Tech White is on patrol.
The radio is how she
shares information.
Tech White works in
the neighborhood.
She drives a police car.
Some patrol officers use
helicopters, or boats,
others ride bicycles
and motorcycles.
Still, others work on horseback.
Patrol officers get
information on the go.
They use technology to
help them do their jobs.
Tech White has a K-9 partner.
K-9 partners are also
called "police dogs."
Tech White K-9 partner
name is, "Officer Hunter."
Sniffing out things is
a K-9 partner's job.
Officer Hunter finds
people in hidden objects,
and he wears a uniform too.
"Do officers have people partners?"
says Ben. "Many do"
says Officer White.
"We also work with other officers
in different towns and cities,
and states, and countries.
By teaming up, we can
keep people safe."
"Go team safety" says Ben.
Not all police officers
work in a neighborhood.
State police patrol highways, they
keep roads safe across the state.
FBI agents protect the country.
They gather information
to fight crime,
and they help catch
people who break the law.
Even we help Team Safety.
We buckle up our seatbelts.
We stand up against bullying.
Even when there's trouble, we, in
the case of emergency, we dial 911.
Officer White makes
our neighborhood safe,
so we give our neighborhood
helper a hand too.
So, you going to give me a hand?
The end.
[ Applause ]
Renee White: Hi.
Good morning.
My names is Officer Renee White.
I've been a United States Capitol
police officer for 16 years.
I started in 1999.
What drew me to police
officers is because I
like talking and helping people.
I like seeking resources,
as far as helping
and making sure everybody's
safe and sound.
This work is kind of
diverse, and so you get
to meet a lot of nice people.
See, I get to meet you, and I
get to meet members of Congress.
I get to meet celebrities,
and everything like that,
so it's kind of working
here on the Hill.
And, you get to travel, I
don't get to travel much,
but I can travel if I like.
But, it's been a good job so far.
>> Karen Jaffe: Tell them where
you started as a police officer.
>> Renee White: Well I started as a
police officer was, I used to work
in jail [chuckle] 1901 District,
and where you kind of lock them up.
I started at the end, so this is
the beginning, and I was there
for like eight years
prior to me coming here.
And, that was a little different
on the other side of the law.
But, it was still fun
helping people.
Yes.
>> Karen Jaffe: Tech Tiffany, do
you want to talk about the dog?
>> Tiffany White: Yes.
My name is Technician White,
and I'm considered a technician,
because I have a K-9, so that's
why this is Officer White
and this is why they
consider me Technician White.
But, I started here eight years ago.
I had a job working in a
lab prior to working here.
And, I started here
straight out of college.
So, I came here because when I was
in school I had some professor's
and teachers who were
talking about law enforcement,
and that was very interesting,
and so I decided to as oppose
to working in the laboratory.
I applied, and that's
how I got here.
So, I've been here for eight years.
I started on the Senate Division
with a lot of our Senators
and congressmen first, and three
years ago I put in to join K-9.
And, from there I joined
the K-9 unit and me
and Hunter started together.
So, we started three years ago.
Hunter actually came here from
Russia, so he's not from America.
He was shipped here from Russia,
and purchased by our department
and we trained together.
So, Hunter and I -- I
didn't know what I was doing
and he didn't know what he
was doing either [laughter].
So, we learned together, and we went
through training for about 17 weeks
which is about three
and a half months.
We trained day in and day out.
And, then he graduated [up,
up, up] and got a badge,
as you can see he got a badge so he
became an official police officer,
and then he came to live with me.
So, Hunter lives at
home with me and he's
with me every day,
all day, every day.
We rarely get time apart.
And, his training is
specific to explosives.
So, explosives would be anything
that could blow up, or explode
and a lot of what we're trained
to do on Capitol Hill is to go
in building, just like
this, we go on busses
that you see driving around here.
We check cars.
We check the grass.
We check trees.
We check every area around the
Capitol to make sure that it's free
from anything that can
potentially explode and harm you all
or anybody else who would be
coming to the Capitol to visit.
So, when you see the dogs out
there, generally they're working
to make sure that you're safe
and everybody else
remains safe on the Hill.
So, it's very intense.
It's a lot of hard training,
but it's very rewarding,
and it's good so that we're
safe and you all are safe too.
Okay.
>> Karen Jaffe: Okay, would
you guys like to ask questions?
If you raise your hand, and we
will try to get you a microphone
if we can, but they
will call on you.
Okay, so one at a time
if you raise your hand.
>> Student: Is it hard
to be a police officer?
>> Renee White: No, it's not
hard to be a police officer.
There's just a lot of
training, that's all.
Concentrating, training, a lot
of running when you first start.
But, you can tell I don't run no
more, s [giggle], 16 years not a lot
of running, but it's not
that much [inaudible].
Just enough.
>> Student: Is it hard to be
a police officer with a dog?
>> Tiffany White: With a dog?
Wow, that's a good question.
It is not hard.
Anyone can do it, you just have
to go through the training,
and you have to always [inaudible].
You know, you see me right
now with the dog and it looks
like he's playing,
he's always working.
So, you got to keep that in mind.
So, that's the only difference.
He's always working.
When he's here he's always working.
Even if it looks like he's
playing, he's working.
So, you have to pay
attention to that.
So, it's not hard.
With the right training and the
practice, you could do it too.
>> Student: Why do
you have to catch --
why do you need cars
to catch bad people?
>> Tiffany White: Sometimes,
depends on where they're located
and you might not be able to get
there on foot, it's quicker to get
to them if you're in a car.
But, we don't just use cars.
We have bikes.
We have motorcycles.
We have some agencies that
have helicopters, planes.
So, cars are just one thing
that we use to catch bad people.
There are other ways that
we can catch them as well.
>> Student: Why do
you all use horses?
>> Renee White: Why do
we -- don't use horses?
>> Student: Why do you have horses?
>> Renee White: Well, we used
to have horses on Capitol Hill,
but park police still have horses.
Yeah, they use them --
I mean because sometimes you can
get there just as quick, you know
and the park is the park,
so it's not a lot of cars
in the park, and it's easy.
There's a lot of grassy areas to
use a horse as opposed to a car.
>> Student: Is it hard
to train dogs?
>> Tiffany White: That's
a good question.
Actually, it's not hard,
but you have to have a dog
who is very willing to listen,
because if the dog doesn't
listen then it's not going
to be easy to train him.
So, a lot of times when you go
through training you may have more
than one dog in the beginning
and you might just end
with the one dog that
listens to you.
So, that's what's important.
You have to have a dog that
listens, but more importantly
that dog has to listen to you.
So, he's very trained to listen
to everything I tell him to,
so that's why he works well.
>> Student: Why do you
work with the Army?
>> Tiffany White: With the Army?
Why do we work with the Army?
It depends on specific
missions that we have,
or different assignments sometimes,
that may require extra help
and we can't do it all on our
own, so we'll work with the Army
to do things here on Capitol Hill.
>> Student: My brother's
in the Army.
So, you -- he uh -- so you --
so you -- you work for the Army?
>> Tiffany White: No, we work
for the U.S. Capitol Police.
>> Student: A cop catch a robber?
A cop catch a robber?
>> Karen Jaffe: He said catch?
>> Tiffany White: Catch.
Yes. That is part of our job.
>> Student: Do you
work with the Navy?
>> Tiffany White: Do
we work with the Navy?
Sometimes, but very rarely.
Very rarely do we work
with the Navy.
>> Student: Why do
you all have guns?
>> Tiffany White: That's
a good question.
>> Renee White: That's
a very good question.
As a police officer that's
part of the description.
Carrying a handgun, and being able
to be equipped and trained to.
>> Student: Just in case the bad guy
or the bad girl tries to shoot you?
>> Renee White: Yes, that's true.
Or, try to do something to
you, yeah [inaudible comment].
You did? You met one?
Did you like her?
>> Student: Yes.
>> Renee White: Good,
because we like to be liked.
It helps our job [giggle].
Yes ma'am?
>> Student: So, you said the dog
came from Russia, so was it easy
for him to translate
to English [inaudible]?
>> Tiffany White: No, and --
it was for me to learn Russian
>> Student: Or, for
you to learn Russian.
Right.
>> Tiffany White: Yes.
Because, I had to learn
certain commands in Russian
when I first got him because that
was all he understood and so --
we would, eventually
keep using Russian,
and then repeat it in English.
>> Student: How's his English?
>> Tiffany White: Oh,
it's good [laughter].
I don't even remember Russian, but
all he understands now is English,
because that's all he's been using.
[inaudible comment].
Oh, we practiced for
about two weeks.
>> Student: Oh wow, okay.
>> Tiffany White: Three
weeks [background comments].
>> Student: I don't have a
question, but I was going
to say something about the dog.
We have a Rottweiler.
My husband is a [inaudible]
police officer, and our dog came
from Germany, and so we had
to go through the same thing.
I understand.
>> Renee White: Yeah.
>> Student: You know, we had to
learn a couple words in German.
But, his training is.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Tiffany White: And
he was, when I got him,
he was two years old,
so he was still a puppy.
He's six now so, it's easy
for him to understand.
I didn't say that.
He's a flat coated retriever.
That's his breed.
I don't know if you have
ever seen a golden retriever
[background comments].
He looks just like them, but his
coat is black as opposed to golden.
>> Student: Do you find that there's
any breed that trains better,
or it depends on the
dog [inaudible]?
>> Tiffany White: Honestly,
it depends on the dog.
Because, we here at Capitol Hill
we have a variety of [inaudible].
>> Renee White: Yeah.
Little dog.
>> Tiffany White: We
have a lot of dogs.
We have a springer spaniel.
We have labs.
We have [inaudible].
We have German Shepherds,
and we have Retrievers.
A lot of it depends on the
dog and the drive of the dog,
their willingness to want to work.
>> Student: Okay.
>> Tiffany White: Yes, because it
could be another dog that looks just
like him, but if they're not willing
to work, or do what's required
of them, then they wouldn't
be a good service animal, so.
>> Student: Why do you have weapons?
>> Tiffany White: Why
do we have weapons?
To protect you and to protect us.
>> Renee White: Yes, yes,
and to protect congressmen.
>> Tiffany White: It's a
tool to keep everyone safe.
>> Renee White: Exactly.
>> Student: Where do you put
the dogs and the bad people at?
[ Background Comments ]
>> Renee White: Say it again.
>> Student: Where do you put
your dogs and the bad people at?
>> Where do we put the
dogs and the bad people?
Well, they go to two
different places.
The dog, he actually stays in the
car, and he also stays in a kennel.
But, the bad people go in a place
like a kennel, it's
a cage in the jail.
That's where we take
people who break the law.
>> Student: Why do you have dogs?
>> Tiffany White: Why
do we have dogs?
We use the dogs for their noses.
Okay, their nose is
what keeps us safe.
Their nose can detect a whole lot
of things that we can't detect.
You know, have you ever been
to Burger King or McDonalds
and you drive up and
you smell french fries?
>> Class: Yeah.
>> Tiffany White: Alright.
Okay, well the dogs, when they
drive up, or when they smell things,
they could smell the
grease in the french fries,
and they can smell the potatoes.
They can smell the salt.
They can break it down in that way.
We smell one thing, but they're
able to break things down in
to multiple components,
or smaller things.
So, that's why we use the dogs,
so they can detect certain smells
and scents in the air and builds in
to animal people, so that they know
if there's any danger
that has the consistency,
or anything that might
hurt you or hurt us.
>> Student: Why -- do you all
have shields under your clothes?
>> Tiffany White: Do
we have shields?
>> Karen Jaffe: Under your clothes.
>> Tiffany White: We do.
We wear a vest.
>> Renee White: Vest here.
It's a big vest, yeah.
>> Tiffany White: We wear
a vest to keep us safe.
>> Renee White: Yes.
>> Tiffany White: So, we
do wear protective gear.
>> Renee White: Yes.
>> Tiffany White: Underneath
our clothing.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> Student: Is the
dog a boy or a girl.
>> Tiffany White: It's a boy.
That's a good question actually.
It's a boy, it's a boy.
>> Student: What do
you use the dogs for?
[ Background Comments ]
>> Tiffany White: Okay,
I'll repeat it.
We use the dogs to help smell
things to make sure that you
and everyone else stays safe.
We use their nose to
help keep us safe.
>> Student: So, you
said Hunter, right?
>> Tiffany White: Yes.
>> Student: You said Hunter
is specialized in explosives,
and you also said that you
use the dogs for noses.
How do they train Hunter to
identify certain explosives?
>> Tiffany White: Okay,
that's a great question.
During our 17 weeks of training,
we will get various components
of explosive materials, and we will
train them based on those scents
to recognize the odors that
the explosives give off.
And from that, they're able to
detect what it is that they need
to find to keep us safe, so.
That's what we do in the training.
They specialize in particular odors.
>> Student: Why do police
officers have badges?
>> Tiffany White: That's
a great one.
>> Renee White: That's
for identification.
Identification purposes, because
her badge is -- it looks the same,
like hers is different than mine.
Can you see them?
But, she has one that
looks just like this too.
But, I don't have one that
looks like that [laughter].
Just to identify.
>> Tiffany White: So, that you
know when you see us we stand out.
>> Renee White: We stand out, yeah.
>> Tiffany White: So,
we're easily identified.
>> Man: Alright, I'm going to do
two more questions [inaudible].
>> Student: How do you
capture the criminals?
>> Tiffany White: How do
we capture the criminals?
There are a lot of
different methods that we use.
It all depends on who the
criminal is, and where they are,
and how do we need to get them.
Do we need a car, bus, train, feet?
We could use one person, we
could use multiple people.
It just really depends
on the situation.
>> Man: Alright, anyone who
hasn't asked a question?
Yeah?
>> Student: How do you
want to be a police?
>> Renee White: Huh?
>> Student: Why do
you want to a police?
>> Renee White: So, I
can help people like you.
Protect you.
I'm here to protect and serve.
>> Karen Jaffe: Okay, here's
what we're going to do.
Very carefully you're going to
get in a line and you're going
to follow the [inaudible], and
we'll stand up, and you'll get
to pet Hunter, but you
have to get in line.
[ Classroom Chatter ]
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.